this past weekend I get that video
firing up all right
I don't always play the music but
sometimes I do
[Music]
good day guys
celebrate net
what you're thinking about the goodness
of the badness today Jeff out there boy
[Music]
you got to have fun man you got to get
keyed into the good parts you know you
got to get keyed into the good parts man
I remember when I was growing up they
had off a cemetery and the cemeteries
where they keep the dead you knows where
it gets basically when I God's filing
cabinets you know it's where they keep
the dead and and a lot of times they had
these dudes that would bury bury people
you know put him in the dirt and some of
the people were people that they didn't
even have funerals for so we go over by
the fence and we watch them do the
burials you know I mean it's almost like
I just kind of just feed and mother just
like it was almost like the like the
earth ate dead bodies and these men were
the UM were the the spoon feeders you
know these mortuary guys he's burial
guys you ever see the thing we're like
somebody like plays with a baby they put
the food on the you know they put them
fancy peaches on the spoon and they they
do the airplane you know that's almost
like what these guys were the burial
guys where they would you know they
wouldn't do the airplane town with the
body and then drop it into the hole but
they would you know they were the guys
that were bringing the the food to the
mouth you know in the food was was the
body in the mouth was um
mother nature earth you know and they
pop they get that orifice open they dig
the dirt out make a hole put the body in
ever we go over there and watch them by
the fence me and my buddy Danny and he
had a bad neck on him he was very light
in the neck I don't know if he had a I
don't know if he had spine in him or if
he was just more uh what is it called
just cartilage
he was thick he was thick and heavy on
cartilage you know
and he are anyway we watched him input
the bear put the ground in put the body
and the thing to cast it and sometimes
they take a break they take a break and
go for a wall go do something else you
know have to cut grass or something you
know and so we'd stand by that fence and
they had a bunch of um they had these
crab apples and they looked like apples
but they were hard so you would get them
if you cooked them down you could eat
them but if you didn't cook them you
could just kind of they were really ripe
you could kind of get a bite one bite
and it was not very good it was not very
good snack but you get one bite and we
try to throw these crab apples into the
open grave if they had an open grave so
sometimes I feel a little bit bad about
that I guess looking back on my own life
you know I'm out there humming apples in
the gravesite you know so just kind of I
don't know if that's bad or good I don't
know you know I don't think uh I don't
think there's any scripture out there or
anything like that that says you can't
you know send somebody up to heaven with
a couple apples in their pockets but we
used to mean me and limp Danny used to
throw them in there throw apples in the
gravesites anyway I don't know why
already off on a tangent
happy happy week it is Monday August 7th
and you're listening to this past
weekend I'm Theo von thank you guys for
being here thank you for being alive you
know you got to be alive to listen
that's the thing as far as we know as
far as we know I hope I hope that's the
case because when I die you can shut the
audio down cat okay you could empty out
my ear holes I don't want to I don't
need any other sound let's want to feel
the joy that's all I want to do man I
just want to be in a damn just that
eternal bubble bath you know with your
loved ones just kind of floating by you
know maybe smoking cigarettes or you
know having them a little bit of a snack
maybe a dessert but I don't want to be
listening and everything I just want to
be able to look somebody in the eyes
when I see them in the afterlife and let
and they'll know that I love them and
they're and I'll know that they love me
that's what I want I don't need to hear
all of this you know I feel like
sometimes would be so much better off if
we didn't have all this sound come
of us but then here I am you know
yelling into a into an empty room here
you know trying to fill up fill up your
side holes in by your brain you know you
all audio batcave so but good to be here
with you guys
happy happy August almost winter do you
realize that it's almost winter and
you're probably gonna be growing a beard
and that's why I've got to say that
Dollar Shave Club is the smarter choice
that's right I'm hittin you guys on an
ad here Dollar Shave Club is a smarter
choice
some people are beard you know you ever
seen some do the beard sometime bald
people grow beard no they can't grow it
on the top they're going to grow it out
the bottom you know just to show that
they still got that power the hair power
but Dollar Shave Club man they got that
new executive razor and that thing it's
like rubbing kind of a strong baby's ass
across your face that thing is its
quality I got it I've been using it I
really have in the shower i VIII I shave
in the shower
you're not shaving the shower probably
like a woman I think a lot of women do
that so I have that in me you know I was
raised by single mothers so maybe that's
where I caught that but when I use my
Dollar Shave Club executive razor with
that dr. Carver's shave butter and it's
just for shape and you can't put it on
bread it makes me feel good I feel a
smooth shave you know I feel like I got
two babies ass cheeks on the side of my
face one on each side not two on one
side I feel good and for a limited time
new members get their first month all of
the executive razor with a tube that dr.
kavas shave butter that's that urban
quality face care right there for only
$5 with free shipping you can get this
offer exclusively at dollarshaveclub.com
slash weekend w ee k ind that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend all
right let's get into what i was up to
this weekend man first i want to say
that it's almost winter you know I saw a
woman this weekend saying she was cold
she's gonna start seeing that I'm cold
I'm cold you know you're going to start
seeing that and I remember they had a
lot of people get violent snowstorms you
know which is a mate
snowstorms are usually you never here oh
we got this comfortable beautiful
snowstorm you always here we got this
violent snowstorm and I don't know where
these snowstorms are learning this type
of behavior you know in the nethersphere
of the weather sphere up there you know
in the in the up there in the balloon
averse up there in the sky I don't know
where they're learning this but they're
coming down here and doing dirt a lot of
them and I remember they had a boy in
our town they had one snowstorm when I
was growing up and I believe that it was
in 1991 and I was in an all-star
basketball league and I was not a very
good basketball player but I think
mentally and emotionally I needed to be
part of that squad and so they put me on
it because some of these men in our town
saw that I needed a little bit extra I
need a little bit of help I needed
something to boost my spirits and
sometimes you do that sometimes you make
somebody a part of something just
because they need it you know it's kind
of like Rob Ryan and Rex Ryan those
coaches that are in the NFL you know
they're no good but you know that that
they might always be heartbroken that
their father was such a good defensive
coach and that they'll never be able to
compete and so they keep them in the NFL
just to kind of boost their spirits and
probably keep them from omitting
themselves from life you know ended up
in a holes where me and light Nick Danny
will be humming apples at him you know
trying to hit him with that vegan diet
on the way out but but let me get back
to what I was saying so you have this
some shoot land brains
oh it was wintertime basketball and snow
hit so they called a timeout for the
whole game in the middle of the game
they call the timeout just and we're
like everybody because everybody ran out
of the game nobody's even watching this
basketball game anymore in our town
people outside throwing playing in the
snow and that's where they had one
icicle I guess it formed and it came
down on a boy out there and he was out
there eating snow one of those kids not
eating yellow snow I know they all have
that old joke don't eat the yellow snow
but this boy was just out there I mean
just snacking on any cold water stack
that he could get his
get his hands on and when he would just
put that snow in a face he was filling
his mouth he couldn't feel his cheeks
anymore he's getting so cold it was
almost like he was when the snow hit he
became mentally handicapped and I grew
up down there in the middlee handicap
belt you know we had a lot of you know
mentals they called them then kids with
the Tizen kids a little bit everything
you know some kids they would say oh he
got bit by a bat you know if they didn't
want to you know make it real scientific
you know because back then it was just
more it didn't matter that you know oh
well he's got you know this blah blah
syndrome or this you know affliction or
this thing or this or it was just you
know oh maybe he got he got rabies you
know he couldn't shake it he got bit by
a bat maybe you know he got hit by
something you got hit by a TransAm and
he hasn't really been exactly the same
person you know his studies have gone
downhill since then you know and that
was okay it was just kind of part of the
way things were it was okay if you had a
handicap you know now everybody we all
look the same you know we all go through
we go through these processes we looked
the same everybody got a straight neck
you know everybody got a straight neck
and everybody got you know white teeth
and everybody has teeth you know I
remember they had a they had to do in
our town he all his teeth he I'm gonna
pee with something's going on with him
and he was you know he used to he had a
lot of his teeth in his pocket and when
he would smile he would he would hold
his mouth open like he was smiling but
they didn't would take his teeth out of
his pocket and show them to you at the
same time so it was almost like he was
it was still a smile technically because
you had both elements of the smile yet
the open mouth and the shape and the joy
in his face but then you had to look at
his hand to see the teeth that were
supposed to be in the smile but I you
know I commend that man because that's
hard work you know when you it's easy
for us to smile we got all our teeth
right there it's one action open the
mouth feel joy throw it at somebody
directionally you know but this man he
had a reach in his pocket when he wanted
to smile at somebody you just show him
the teeth and he kept them clean but
anyhow this one boy went out into the
snow
and and he got hit by an icicle dude and
his cheeks were already fillies up
they're just you know filling up on snow
and maybe they've been poor and they
were huh you know who knows I mean when
snow falls for the first time in your
life you have people collecting it you
know some people thought it was like a
collector's item you know you had people
you know bury and stuff and people you
know saving and bathing water boiling
things in it
you know you had people doing prayers
and all kinds of stuff and writing
prayers out in the snow and all kinds of
stuff you know you had people just you
know drawing crosses and getting new
tattoos and do-it-yourself tattoos and
all that cat [ __ ] you know you had the
activities you had the joy because there
was excitement it was something new you
know it's probably the first time you're
in an earthquake sure you're like oh
this is scary and you know sure you know
is you know are the birds okay or is the
good China gonna has it fallen but you
also got that feeling of man what did I
just go through you know what is Mother
Nature look at the powers that she has
out here you know she's out here Hogwart
you know she's out here as ithacus mana
caucus you know she's got her activities
and that's what you felt the power but I
remember they had an icicle that a big
icicle and this boy it must have fallen
off of a tree I can't remember the tree
or the side of gymnasium clip this boy
right in the right in like the side of
his entire neck and your head kind of
combined each other behind the ear and
man kid was never the same he was never
the same after that great weather
adventure of 1991 I believe it was and I
was Covington we were playing against a
Holy Cross which was um which was some
other basketball team well what's going
on with you guys man I try to look at
the news
there's still time I Russia you know so
I can't look at it anymore
I mean I still can't it's it's beyond me
you know I'm just over it man you know
and the truth is everybody acts like
everything's so wrong with the world
with the plan and everything all of a
sudden let me tell you about my weekend
I live here in Los Angeles you know
where a budget I mean you got some
people out here been bit by the liberal
bat you got some people out of their
minds living on an island they don't
even not even living in reality okay
people are afraid to probably leave the
state because they might learn what
other people's lives are like and other
people's existences are actually like
but man you had I mean everything was
fine this weekend you know I worked on
the television show for Comedy Central
you know what does it have a young
fellow this guy Trevor Moore has a new
show on there and I got to play a
homoerotic CrossFit boy and I think I
did fairly well I hope I brought
something to his project a very funny
young man and I was just happy to be
there you know to be of service and Abby
you noticed part of whatever was going
on so that made me feel pretty good
honest to be to be there and be able to
do that and that'll be coming out I
think in the spring I'll let you guys
know and then what else man I got
invited to the Beverly Hills hotel pool
to hang out with some friends that
sounds fancy to some of you guys sounds
fancy to me I didn't go though kept it
easy you know spend a little time with
this lady kept it easy you know kept it
easy this weekend but I'll just tell you
this that everything's fine out here
people are still eating people are still
driving around in Lamborghinis and
living their lives there's still like
people rescuing animals out of the trees
that don't want to be rescued
I saw a lady in the park the other day
saying she's rescuing birds I'm like
[ __ ] you are kidnapping animals these
birds came to that tree of their own
volition of their own will and she out
there trying to get these birds saying
they're homeless I'm like [ __ ] these
are birds okay so I know some of you
know some some some liberal people what
are you doing at a certain point you
rescuing animals from nature because
guess what guess what
nature is made of let me think I don't
know animals so don't be out there
taking birds out of trees and saying you
some kind of rescue artist you know
saying you some damn Amelia Earhart of
the aviary universe
leave birds and trees equipped as
[ __ ] man going too far you know so
it's just I mean it's bad [ __ ] out here
man
but yeah it's crazy people act on social
media like the world is oh you know this
and the presidency in this way really I
think what if the politicians ever done
they've all politics is a rich man's
game let me say that
okay I'll agree with you maybe it's some
small town some state levels it can be a
poor man's game but you pilot politics
is a rich man's game when was the last
time we had a politician that wasn't a
millionaire
you know like a woman's iPhone well I
won't say a politician about a president
was also made a president that wasn't a
millionaire I mean you got to be
disconnected you know at that point how
disconnected are you you know I just get
that's my thing it's like politics never
I felt like did much for me you know I
didn't care who the president was
because I mean I you know I I was
excited by it at times if I would get to
meet the president I didn't really care
because I think he's gonna stop by my
neighborhood you know we used to have
somebody used to throw dead animals in
our ditch we called for about five years
trying to get him a stop it and nobody
would stop and they were throwing dead
animals out there I think it was some
veterinarian some bootleg veterinarian
so what I'm saying is if you're sitting
around bitching about politics on any
side of the net don't you worry about
the politics in your own life that's
what we have to do and look I find
myself getting into it too I mean you
got people out here rescuing birds out
of trees families of birds being broken
up why because they're in a tree [ __ ]
they are Birds so I just don't know
what's going on man when I went out to
breakfast today though I you know with a
buddy of mine it was good to catch up
and I had french toast to it I'm you'd
like that you know when just went wild
you know just sugar to the faces and I
like to do french toast the
old-fashioned way you know kind of that
arm that Italian style where you put the
syrup in your mouth first
and then you put the French toast in
some people like to mix it out here in
the wild when your plate I don't do that
to me that's like getting dressed in
public you know I like to do it in
private in the inside of my mouth that's
how I like to have my french toast you
know so first get that hit off that
frickin L cabin you know and then drop
that ftz in your man you know I'm saying
then you mMmmm you doing that magic
behind closed doors other people out
here doing their French toast out on
their plate do come on don't be a
pervert
you know get it together know how to eat
french toast so that's how I feel about
that man but yeah it was good to be it
good to be alive this weekend man and I
hope it was you too
I got some cool stuff coming up you know
always hit the dates and everything and
I got to remind you guys I'll be in
Dallas next weekend you got a new friend
in Dallas an old friend anyone an ex a
lover or a current a stepfather you know
a foster care somebody that came through
your home in foster care years ago and
you forgot about them send them out to
my show I'll be there at the Addison
improv August 10th through the 13th
September 6 6th through the 9th I
believe I will be in Austin at cap city
comedy club 14th through the 17th of
September I'll be at Cleveland
hilarities and it looks like we will be
getting a date for Vancouver that will
probably be August 30 a September 1st
excuse me out of belt store burped I
don't know which one it was and then
I'll be in Huntsville Alabama
November 16th through the 19th you can
find all of those tickets at theof on
comm / tour t oh you are against it some
calls and a lot of great ones come in I
got to go to the to the improv and a
little bit into a comedy set then I got
to do six comedy sets last night that
was pretty cool you know at one point I
was performing this walk a no volcanoes
a it's a restaurant of sorts if you want
to call it that it's a you know it's a
fish house pretty urban out here you
know it's kind of more of an urban crowd
which finds kind of just let you know
the environment over there and they have
these pop-up comedy shows and they have
actually pop-up comedy shows everywhere
now I guess where you
can follow a group on Facebook and it's
like a pop-up group and the next thing
you know they're like okay we're having
a pop-up this and it can be a barbecue
comedy show clothing sale it could be
anything
childcare we haven't pop-up childcare
out here at the mortuary you know you
could drop off your dead and drop off
little Freddie and we'll take care of
his ass you know we'll take care of both
of them just pick up Freddie in about
four hours you know but they have like
it's just a surprise business that would
normally be in that location in in a
certain location and so they had two of
them this weekend last night one of them
was in a backyard of an apartment
complex regular apartment complex you
know some families some lesbians some
single men that seemed like kind of the
clientele and then in the backyard I
guess they got permission for somebody
to put together a big stage and next
thing you know there's probably out I
would say maybe 90 people sitting out
there just watching comedy enjoying
their own hometown their own their own
you know living room refreshments and
just enjoying comedy right there and
that was pretty cool to see managed to
be a part of that and then another one
was at a walk a no next type of sushi
food restaurant and we did that one as
well that was a little bit weirder kind
of some rich people and rich people
sometimes they're disconnected you know
they're disconnected from the reality is
they think the things you're talking
about they just can't get it sometimes
because they're disconnected or they're
afraid to laugh it's almost sometimes
the elite sometimes the rich people
sometimes they're afraid to laugh at
poor people it's like they're giving
them something you know or when they do
laugh sometimes to me sometimes it
appears like they they're doing you a
service you know hahaha yeah I'm cool
I'll be okay you know but I hit them
hard I said look I don't care if you
guys laugh I know this stuff's funny I'm
going to be fine either way and that's
where I'm at with comedy these days may
not yeah I'll do my best to make you
laugh because that's my job
but if you think I'm going to sit there
and feel bad if you don't or feel a
certain way I'm not doing that [ __ ]
anymore man I do well at my job I am
good at my job that's what I mean
I'm not saying I'm the most famous
comedian I'm not saying I'm the best
comedian but I will say that I work hard
at my job and I do and I do it well and
if you come out and see that you will ah
you'll get a little hit of that and I
think some of this stuff I'm just saying
this to it because I need to say it you
know I never say this kind of stuff to
myself you know and sometimes that inner
dialogue in me and my life that you know
the inner things that my brain tells me
are the things I say to myself aren't
always the most positive so you know and
sometimes I don't know where that comes
from
you know I'm still trying to dig into
certain parts of my life in my past to
know where that comes from but but I
know that it's in me that you know
sometimes you know you know my brain
doesn't want to take care of me as much
as it as it should it doesn't want to
have as much confidence in me as it
should or as I do so it's you know it's
just um you know just stay aware of that
and try to work through it that's what
I'm doing so appreciate you guys being
here with me in that moment where I just
you know kind of did a little bit of
that alright I'm going to get to a
couple of texts and calls people hit the
hotline and I want to thank you guys for
hitting the hotline that number is nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three I'm going to change the voicemail
on it just to give everybody a little
bit more information but the hotline you
can call about anything question
concerned something going on in your
life that maybe you're looking for you
know a young man to relate to some
things I won't be able to relate to some
things I have no thoughts or suggestions
about but if it's something that I can
share relate to you know I'll do my best
to share and I appreciate you guys
sharing I really really do all right
let's hit let's hit a couple of calls
here we go
[Music]
hey Phil this is Cody Cohen from Boulder
Colorado as Cody in Boulder Colorado
thank you for calling Cody onward big
fan of the show love what you do thick
you're the freakin man you just have
such a unique perspective on life I love
the way you communicate it Thank You Man
I appreciate saying that I'm just trying
you know I'm just trying to
to stay stay stay stay alive let's go
thank you reason I'm calling
I'm just curious on your thoughts on
something I'm sure you've heard about a
bunch you see it all the time texting
and what people are doing on their
phones nowadays I've been going to fold
play a bunch oh wow
could have been going to Chipotle and in
some people that's a Mexican restaurant
some people realize that some people
that's a Mexican restaurant when I was
growing up I went over to high school
Mandeville Louisiana we got a Taco Bell
and suddenly things got Mexican you know
and that was a Mexican restaurant for us
and then somebody actually and this is
going to sound a little bit vulgar but
in 1996 somebody pooed in the meat
service worker there got angry there was
some staff issues and somebody you know
uh you know did a little bit of a you
know make you know a little bit of a
excretory in the meat there and they had
to shut it down for about a year I might
have went out of business I don't
remember but that was tough time for our
town Almer Cody's heart interrupt you
every time I go there people literally
can't help themselves but to look at
their phone while they're waiting in
line and it's like 90 plus percent of
people they can't they can't stop
themselves and has never been a big fan
of this whole phone culture and what has
turned into and turns pain now with
people everybody's on their phones all
the time and it's one of your thoughts
on it what you think about what's going
on in this weird world we've come into
sorry I got some coffee stuck in my
throat well yeah I mean look what buddy
of mine just said he got text neck and
text neck is some tightening of the
muscles and some vertebrae issues you
can get from the constant being down
looking down I think that it definitely
makes us dumber over time because we're
not our heads aren't up here we're not
as alert and aware so our awareness is
in time could be affected I was sitting
at a table or some the other day and
some girls said that kids are being born
with like indentations and their fingers
from where their parents like always
holding holding their cellphone
you know like their pinky finger has
like an indent on it from where it the
cell phone rests on it and I thought
that that girl was out of her [ __ ]
mind but it did make me start to think
how many things could be genetic
like how many you know based on us being
addicted to our phones and I'm going to
say addicted because I the one thing
that I have withdrawals from is my phone
if I can't find my phone I get you can
feel it in your body when you can't find
it and that's withdrawals that's not
like oh I just can't find my phone
that's a real thing you know when you
can't leave home without it when you
can't go like that's addiction and it's
interesting how it's okay to be addicted
to our phone but it's not okay to be it
you know like addiction is usually bad
but with our phones it's it's like we
accept it like it's okay like it's a
means to like it's a means to something
so it's a good question I worry about it
too and I don't know what the answers
are I don't know if at some point do we
start to you know lose like our feeling
of like peripheral awareness because
we're so right here looking at a screen
that would make sense to me because if
our old screen was our eyes looking out
you know just the world in front of us
and our new screen is just this little
world in our hands then you would think
that our ability to interpret and
awareness would would manifest or would
adjust to adapt to this new screen over
time so yeah I'm curious but how long is
that kind of stuff take you know for a
human to genetically adjust like through
like generation a generation I have no
idea but it makes me scared for sure you
know meeting people is old-fashioned you
know if you I mean look we go to the
fist bump now
I thought about this the other day like
I always used to scrapbook brah be real
about that [ __ ] you know I mean I was
the only dude you knew probably in you
know when I was a freshman in college I
was doing steroids and scrapbooking you
know what I'm saying man I was out in
both games and if I tell people oh I see
a scrapbook people will I go look at
this my hug you know look at it why's
that you know look at this boy coming a
little bit lavender he coming in a
little bit lavender but the truth is cat
daddy okay you're on Instagram now
aren't you well all of a sudden
everybody a scrapbooker because I told
Instagram is a scrapbooking
how many everybody's a scrapbooker now
so maybe I was progressive if I think
about it like that maybe I was early to
the game but it's very scary man it's
very scary to think what's going to
happen you know because I know that I'm
addicted
you know I deal with addiction in other
parts of my life or you know have chosen
to look at that and I'm but I noticed it
was my phone I notice it that's a real
thing
how do we beat it do we beat it there's
no going back
you know where it's like we're not going
to go back to a time where we don't use
our phones I don't think you know I
don't think at all now do we start to
monitor it if there become health
serious health risks then that could be
something that happens I mean we're
really an experimental time because
we've never had you know we're kind of
the first generation you know at my age
I'm kind of the first generation where
you know I started using a phone a cell
phone when I was 20 you know we're going
to find out what the long-term effects
are so who knows what if our legs fall
off in a couple of months you know this
huge class action lawsuit against AT&T
you know can you imagine even just all
the wheelchairs trying to show up at the
courthouse [ __ ] could get wild
let's hit another call right here a
fieldset that smiles I just wanted to
call them thank you for reaching out to
me on your video and everything I
thought that was pretty cool
um thanks for calling miles I've been I
just got sober I a sober for like a
month and then I relapsed on heroin but
now I'm I'm two weeks clean so yeah you
know I just wanted to you know say thank
you I listen to your advice and it
actually really helps suck yeah thanks
and I'll uh I'll keep watching the
podcast all right have a good day
appreciate you calling miles yeah and
look man thank you for thank you for
reaching out and for sharing you know
what's going on with you with us
congratulations on you know choosing to
look at what's going on in your life and
the battle your addiction I'm sorry to
hear about that relapse but you sound
good man you sound good on that call for
sure you know and I know you say you use
the word advice and I'm not trying to
correct you're anything but i'ma say I
just you know I don't really have advice
but I do I do want to share if I can you
know but I'm proud of you dude you know
it really makes me kind of feel
something here you say that so you're
welcome
you know it's tough dude it's tough when
when you find yourself in certain
situations where you you know you get to
a point for some reason you feel empty
or you feel alone or you feel scared or
whatever it is that manifests into you
where where it calls you to to abuse
drugs you know and then once you start
to do that then the drugs can start to
abuse you because they have powers
themselves you know making you nurse
making us addicted so I appreciate you
reaching out man and I hope you'll call
in and reach out again dude I'd love to
maybe do a follow up with you and see
what's going on you know but I really
appreciate it dude and I wish you the
best you know you're fighting some
battles I might you know that's ballsy
man you're out there really fighting
some stuff and I don't know if I could
do that but I commend you for calling in
and sharing your strength because that
makes me feel it makes me feel good to
hear that honestly you know and that's
really what
you know going to some of these programs
is about it's about you know that we get
to share and and just realize we're not
alone dealing with [ __ ] so I got your
back Playboy you feel me
thank you for calling man onward onward
ACO is Nick I'm coming them I know used
by English people out but I'm a that's
Nick from England thank you for calling
Nick I don't look man I've got two other
works with some great British people my
issues with the British are this that
the rest of the world gets stuck dealing
with a lot of [ __ ] that the British
caused British did a lot of dirt
[ __ ] and the rest of us are still
out here dealing with it you know I mean
Africa y'all took almost all the good
stuff out of Africa you know y'all put
that straw in there like the man says on
that there will be blood and drank that
dark milkshake you know slanting them
diamonds and everything up in your mouth
so that's just my tough thing with that
with uh with Britain sometimes and then
we have a lot of British show hosts you
know America has gotten obsessed or at
least Hollywood has with with putting
you know putting British into a lot of
American roles and I think it's great
but also I'd like to see somebody that
grew up here in some roles you know and
I think I start to feel angry personally
about that because you don't see a lot
of southerners in roles every southerner
gets looked at like oh there's some
[ __ ] worm eaten fish strangling idiot
well that's not the case you know that's
not the case you know a lot of us are
educated you have a southern accent
doesn't mean we're ignorant you know and
I think that some of that starts to
resonate in me and it all kind of mixes
and flares up and I know I'm being all
over the place here but I want to tell
you just tell you a little bit more of
my thoughts behind some of that and the
Patriot is my favorite movie
now Patriots a good move you haven't
seen that Mel Mel Gibson big hair
beautiful hair he got that Michael
Landon follicle reach you know on his
neck on his uh on his hood ornament and
it's beautiful man too
if you look into his eyes like God got
damn man that do got crystal balls in
his face
and so he's a beautiful man I know he's
you know he you know he was offered the
mouth sometimes but a lot of people do
you know I'm not defending them but a
man got beautiful any and he beat the
British in about two hours and ten
minutes and that movie the patriot one
of my favorite movies but I do
appreciate you calling and and I you
know I respect what you you know I
respect the British you know you guys uh
you guys been out there you guys been in
the game so onward I've been listening
this everything every week um thank you
I'm listening to your podcast I love
them thank you love you brother
turning present is having some chemo
issues so was married had a kid and
basically the best sex I've had in my
life was with this woman so saying he's
married he had a child and the best sex
I ever had was with this woman okay
onward and everyone I'm with since I
can't stop thinking about my ex-wife you
know but motion we all get on so how do
you deal with that how do you deal with
how do you do with sex good-looking
women too emotionally connecting with
all you know that's why I ask anyway
love you podcast and respond please
Nick I appreciate your calling from
across the pond man and you know and
I'll say this to the British were bosses
man you know people want to say this and
that and I'm one of those people you
know sitting there just riling in but
you know if there's another way to look
at it the British were straight-up Boss
Hogg's you know you always frickin
throwing bacon and breast milk all
around the universe and doing things
like you wanted to do at a time and that
was the way to do you know to be out
there conquistadora n-- you know in game
of thrones and taking people's heads off
you know and keeping them in special
souvenir cases and y'all were out there
doing that kind of stuff and in that
time it was a battle atmosphere y'all
won you know y'all won so but I do
appreciate you call a man how do I deal
with that kind of stuff like thinking
back on some of the best sex
I'll tell you this you can get addicted
to a certain type of sex you had or some
experience you had you know some you
know I had a early sexual partner and
things got straight wild you know you
got things got pretty wicked things you
type a see on the Internet
you know that internet sex you know I'm
talking about that jungle book sex you
know what I'm saying but you know I'm
talking about a tan people jumping up
and down on bit on big bears of belly
tops while they float in the river I'm
talking about the wild Katniss you know
and and yeah you can get addicted to
some of that kind of stuff you know so I
think sometimes it is tough to move on
and if that's the case you might want to
see a sexual therapist about it and talk
to them because there's probably some
you know there might be more issues
behind that how do I deal with sex these
days well I mean I find even sex is
something that you can get addicted to
if you're not careful I mean sex is fun
sex is a something that makes you feel
good you know sex is something that you
know if you get stuck with it right
there then you might not be able to then
connect with somebody we're here let me
put it like this like you know like
anything second get something you can be
addicted to but if you're if you're
having trouble finding the same type of
sex with a new partner
I mean maybe just you're not over the
old old partner yet that's one thing it
could be you know now for me I know that
I'm over you know the previous partner I
was just you know the sex was something
that was really kind of spectacular but
these days man I'm older you know I'm
more neurotic you know I get some
intimacy issues when it comes down to
sexual activity you know and so I got to
battle through that some of that like
that's the thing getting old right I
think back in the day we're only
supposed to live to probably 18 years
old or 26 years old you know if you look
at Michael Landon times you look at you
know the proverbial time is back then I
don't even know what proverbial means
but if you look back on that you'll see
that we're not supposed to be alive this
long
so when people out here you know humping
and you know insert and dick and
everything out here at you know 35 45 70
you know my father had me at 70 that
dude was throw-in dick in 1980 at 70
years old so there's a lot of stuff
behind the dick at that point you know a
lot of you know could be insecurities
anxieties that sort of thing you know
but maybe I think sometimes it takes the
right person to come along to where you
feel comfortable again so maybe you're
kind of waiting for that you know me you
might have some remorse from the first
relationship that you haven't let go of
you know and maybe you maybe there's
some of the sexual memories are the last
thing that you hold on to because you're
afraid to let go of those because then
you you know I don't know if you're
still with your ex-wife but it sounds
like you're not then maybe you'll feel
like you have nothing unless you hold on
to that memory of the sex you know I
don't know I don't know if sex is the
reason why you guys split up maybe if
you were outside of you know I'm not
accuse him but if you were you know
venture and elsewhere and then sometimes
I think that sex is one thing and that
being in love with somebody's another
thing you know I mean it's really I mean
I was talking to a friend this morning
about he said man I you know I can fall
in love once I fall in love I just can't
have set I just am NOT sexually
attracted to a woman and for me this
goes back to I think these days a lot of
men are looking for mothers and there's
something that happened with our
generation where men just were not
mothered enough and so they're looking
for mothers when it comes to partners
and then they they're not looking for
you know it's not the sex that attracts
them as much anymore you know it's they
want that motherhood first from their
from their spouse and then also now sex
is so readily available everywhere you
know sex is so it's like you know before
you even lay down at night with your
wife or girlfriend you've seen 70
pictures of tits on Instagram or this or
that or there's just sex is everywhere
so we're really oversexed a lot of times
you know so it's hard to even have as
strong sexual feelings that could be it
you know maybe if this was 15 years ago
when you fell in it you know fell in
love with your
why for whatever and the sex is great
everything was because maybe you it was
15 years ago he had 15 less years of
exposure to you know that you know the
sex that's out there stuff on the
internet or you know people showing a
tits at bus stops and everything I
remember a homeless lady I somebody had
jumped off a building in New York City
and I walked up and she goes did you see
it and I'm looking trying to look over
the crowd at the for the you know see a
little bit of light you know just get a
quick glimpse of the body or something
or see if anything hit an awning and
this lady said did you see it I'm like
what and then she just showed me her her
crotch you know this lady's showing her
crotch ah and nobody else saw every
people all just looking I'm like what
the [ __ ] going on you know when ready
to see any crotch at that time I just
wanted to especially when you're looking
to maybe maybe get a glimpse of a body
that you know just flew off of 56
stories and then surprised you see
crotch I mean that could be severely
damaging to someone's you know sexual
equilibrium you know so I mean with
intimacy I don't deal with it super well
these days man you know I have a tough
time you know sometimes figuring that
stuff out and I don't think I'm bizarre
in that because so many of my friends
have a tough time too I think it's some
that super untalked about you know but I
don't have any shame about it you know
like I've had taken many lovers in my
life you know you know I feel confident
in myself but I still feel you know I
feel like there's a lot of you know
sometimes it's a smoothie in my brain
when it comes to sex and intimacy and
and wanting to figure out you know how
do you make that work in a relationship
and in a marriage and and how the
present-day environment affects all of
that and you know with this stuff that
were exposed to and pornography how does
it all fold together it's tough I know
there's a book out there called a fear
of intimacy which I heard is really good
then I'm about to read you know I don't
know what some of your issues could be
ma'am but I appreciate you calling in
about
you know and and I hope that you know me
thinking about it was mildly at least
you know entertaining for you let me see
if we can get in win one more call I got
to go do a set in a few minutes here we
go
I feel this is Angela I love your show I
just want to ask you a question about
what people say and how it affects us
okay this is Angela thank you for
calling Angela you sound like a lovely
lady and I appreciate it and what people
say and how it affects us okay I'm
listening when I was about 15 the boy
that I had a huge crush on made a
comment about my arms being really hairy
and ever since I've shaved my arms every
day and I was like 15 years ago
so it's crazy because like clearly I
don't give a [ __ ] about it now
but I still shave my arms just wondering
if that's if there's something similar
that you have and then if other people
have the same thing keep up what you're
doing love the show alright bye okay
Angela thanks for calling that's
interesting so some boy told you you had
hairy arms you started shaving your arms
and what and you and you don't even
think about the boy anymore
but you're still living the shaved armed
life and that for some reason that
really stuck in you Wow Wow it's
powerful to think about because you know
I just remember a camp counselor one
time at YMCA summer camp saw me coming
out of my apartment complex that I lived
in and he made fun of me that day in
front of some of the other camp
counselors and before that I didn't
really feel a lot of shame but after
that I felt so ashamed about where I
lived and since then I've always had a
little bit of shame about about my home
it's crazy the things that people say
and how they carry on with us forever
you know or sometimes they do it's a
good question I mean that's a good
question I think for everybody to ask
themselves any of any of the listeners
uh you know who are who are still
listening right now this past weekend
what's something that somebody told you
you know a put-down or
something that affected the way that you
thought of yourself or something there
how you then changed yourself or a
ritual or something you started that you
continue to do you know there's all
kinds of things for me when I think
about it
you know I remember people telling me I
had buttocks like a Down syndrome boy
when I was young and I had a good friend
who had Down syndrome and sometimes I
felt pride because we had similar kind
of backsides and then but ever since
then I you know I do feel sometimes a
little bit nervous about it when I you
know I'm wearing certain types of
clothes maybe let me think about what
else um you know I have a big nose of a
wide nose so I think about that
sometimes people would always you know
actually people wouldn't always make fun
of it but like around the neighborhood
people would say stuff you know let me
think about other things that I had big
ears growing up and so that made me
self-conscious I used to sleep with like
this like a church tie or tie you know
tied around my head you know and I'd tie
it around my head at night to kind of
hold my ears back and that you know that
was crazy but the biggest one for me was
that I felt shame about my home you know
Oh a girl told me that she liked my eyes
one time and I guess I didn't feel a lot
of a lot of nice comments from women
growing up and so she told me she liked
my eyes so then I started getting
addicted to eye drops I remember and for
years I was addicted eye drops I mean
probably eight years I had two things
I've drops on me at all times and I was
constantly did I was probably doing 50
drops a day in each eye I mean I was I
had a eight dollar a day I drop habit
and that's it's really unheard of what
else I don't know it's interesting and
I'd love to know assume you guys are
maybe we should maybe we'll pull out
right here for the day man we'll pull
out right here for the day hit the
hotline what's something that somebody
said to you one time you know that
affected the way you thought about
yourself for a change that it's created
ritual or something
did even though you might not even
remember who did it anymore but you
still do that I mean it's crazy to think
that Angela is out there shaving her
arms baby man you must have some real
Bobcats at the end do elbows you know
but um but you sound like a beautiful
person and you know I'd let you hug me
with them ding you know with them doing
beautiful I'd give them arms a fade why
but you got some serious hair gravitas
coming out of those things but you're
welcome to hug me with them anytime
anytime you want anytime I see you and I
appreciate you concert it's interesting
to think about I'm gonna think about it
too and I'm gonna come back next week
and kind of share with you guys a lot of
people wondering why did it why don't I
do a Thursday pickup episode of follow
up because I want to start doing that on
Thursdays well for one the studio is not
done yet we had to order some other
stuff I got one new microphone spent
five hundo on this thing so really
excited to have it it's a you know it's
a big addition and but for to the we
ordered some stuff it didn't come in yet
so we couldn't get it done but I'm
trying I'm still working towards it and
I appreciate you guys as patience but I
booked that thing for Comedy Central
side to work it was that literally got
the call at 5:00 p.m. and the next thing
you know the whole day I'm working on
the set all day the next day but I was
really happy and feel pretty grateful
that you know that that kind of stuff
happened because I don't book a lot of
stuff but I know when I get down set I'm
feeling a lot more confident these days
and I'm pulling I'm pulling it off baby
we're going to do good things and I
appreciate you guys love and support
so yeah hit the hotline nine eight five
six six four nine five zero three I want
to thank all of our callers who called
in and I want you to hit me up and let
me know yeah
what's your angeles story you know
what's your thing that that hit you
what's what's your thing that got you
you know that somebody said you still do
you still carry out a you know something
you do you know you put on extra
lipstick or you do your hair a certain
way or i mean for sure i remember being
young i was really thin growing up and
that's what got me into using some
performance-enhancing drugs people just
making fun of the way that my body
looked or just calling me skinny i just
i was so desperate for
acceptance from people that when someone
didn't accept me at all it just really I
didn't have any defenses against that
because no one ever taught them to me
but I'm an adult now and and now if I'm
still living that way then now it's my
fault you know it's my fault if I
continue to live that way so now I got
to be cognizant of those things and if
they come up I got to figure out what's
going on why is it going on and and then
start to find a solution and a lot of
times that solution is just you know
sharing it with somebody who can who can
who can help me figure it out but I
appreciate you guys : appreciate
everything let's get out of here give a
spencer jacob growl I'll put the link I
think they have a new album out I'll put
the link on the YouTube page of the
YouTube will go up I think Monday night
and this is Monday morning remember if
you want to support Dollar Shave Club
it's dollarshaveclub.com slash weekend
for $5 for that deal and also we're
still going to the patreon I had people
hit me up about that as well it's just
been hard it's been hard to do a lot of
stuff forget a lot of cool things going
on I appreciate your love appreciate the
support y'all be good thank you for
being a part of this past weekend
[Music]
every frame is
I'm gonna die let's have some fun well
we want to thank all of our callers to
man talk about text neck tricky Nick
that cold in he's bout that battle as a
diction man you we got your back but you
can do it man just one one day at a time
bud you know and find friends you know
just find friends you don't have to do
it by yourself man it's going to be good
it's going to be good man you can do it
you know you got this playboy all right
I'll talk to you guys next week man
be good to yourselves because I bet you
deserve it I bet you do thank you